si vous étiez avec nous au début de
cette édition philippe brillault le
maire du chesnay conseil général des
yvelines est resté en plateau avec nous
tout à l'heure nous parlions
moralisation de la vie politique
maintenant on va parler également du
mariage pour tous le texte a été adopté
hier en lecture solennelle à l'assemblée
nationale pour l'anecdote le député des
yvelines henri guaino a voté pour
députés ump qui a avoué s'être trompé
tout simplement dans les dents les
boutons ça vous fait sourire mais au
final ça a une âme il des erreurs cédric
terre c'était un dernier qui sauve elle
fait c'était assez embêtant pour henri
guaino de se tromper lui qui s'est battu
contre ce projet de loi qui est
aujourd'hui une loi comme c'est
aujourd'hui une loi il reste encore
ensuite la saisie du conseil
constitutionnel mais est-ce que vous
allez ou non célébrer les mariages ou
est-ce que vous vous iso opposerait en
tant que maire alors si les textes de
promulgation passe et que le conseil
constitutionnel donne son accord et
célébrer les mariages je ne ferai pas de
mariage homosexuel vous n'entrez pas
dans votre mairie ni vous ni vos
adjoints vous m'avez posé une question
pour moi et vous êtes réellement je ne
ferai pas vous n'empêcherez pas besoin
de le faire je ne répondrai pas pour mes
adjoints je sais déjà ce qu'ils pensent
et de toutes les façons il y aura
toujours une délégation possible puisque
le maire les adjoints paul de faire si
je refuse la délégation le mariage peut
pas se faire il ya une loi nous ferons
ce qu'il faut pour la faire respecter
vous ferez comment qui célébrera ses
mariages sans âge je peux donner une
délégation un membre du conseil sur 35
j'ai deux membres de gauche dont vous
voyez que la majorité comme plutôt de
notre côté mais je resterai composer ce
genre d'aspect canada mais minorité qui
acceptera de recevoir ma délégation pour
le faire le mouvement va se poursuivre
ou ailleurs je voulais jouer juste dire
que je verrai les gens avant parce que
qui se sont déchaînées gien il me paraît
normal de les accueillir et je leur
expliquerai parce que ce sont des
électeurs aussi potentiel il ya des
échéances et vous êtes candidat qu'il
faut aussi respecter les électeurs le
problème j'ai toujours travaillé en
fonction ce que je pensais le mouvement
va se poursuivre ou non doit bien sûr
tous bien sûr puisque cette fusée à deux
étages il y avait l'union des adultes et
puis ensuite elle doit l'enfant donc mon
combat est le combat de beaucoup c'est
par rapport aux enfants par rapport à la
filiation la procréation et on voit bien
se profiler la pma autres donc notre
combat continu dessus mais continue
toujours la loi n'est pas encore n'est
pas encore appliqué un excellent mois
pisam asie vous offrait moi même les
mariages avec le texte actuel mais est
ce que vous appeler au calme pour autant
parce qu'on le voyait encore des
débordements ça a été la situation était
tendue aux invalides encore hier après
le vote de cette loi est ce que vous
aviez hier soir j'étais hier soir à
23h30 aux invalides il y avait une
ambiance extraordinaire il n'y a pas eu
de débordement il ya eu toujours des
pizzas des petits excitation c'était
extraordinaire et moi je pense qu'il
faut respecter ces gens il ya plus de
dix mille personnes hier est ce que on
est agité excité non est ce qu'on est
agacé profondément est-ce qu'on est
nombreux wii est agacé et nombreux
qu'est ce que ça peut faire c'est une
révolte aujourd'hui nous sommes dans
face à une révolte est ce que vous
appelez plutôt calme où est ce que vous
appelez justement à cette révolte non
moi je ne veux pas absolument je ne suis
pas du tout pour le calme je suis pour
continuer notre action qui doit être
couplée avec les manifestations dans la
rue c'est la manif pour tous et puis les
actions politiques parce que question
politique réponse politique et henri
guaino a été extraordinaire je suis
désolé qu'il soit trompé de bouton
décidément dans les yvelines on a des
problèmes de boutons il ya deux manières
qui s'est trompé et puis maintenant il
ya henri guaino le dernier qui devait le
faire mais il faut reconnaître qu amaury
guaino que c'est quand même un sacré
guerrier et que depuis pas mal de
semaines et mois il s'est engagé vous
parlais justement de l'aspect politique
c'est la suite qui sera donnée à ce
mouvement aussi maintenant qu'il se pose
est ce qu'il y aura par exemple c'est ce
qu'a laissé entendre frigide bardot ou
encore christine boutin des candidats
manif pour tous aux élections
municipales vous croyez pas que 730
milles pétition citoyenne montre qu'il y
ait un désaveu des partis politiques ça
veut dire qu'aujourd'hui un rassemblés
dans votre mairie d'ailleurs je leur
précise puisque vous n'avez pas dans la
mairie mais dans la commune dans des
salles mises à disposition notre
association la transparence politique
vous l'avez dit tout à l'heure donc oui
sept cent trente mille personnes ont
montré qu'il était nécessaire qu'il y
ait une action aujourd'hui du peuple
pour reprendre le pouvoir c'est cela et
je pense que les partis politiques en
sont conscients et sont en train de
regarder le sujet ça veut dire par
exemple sur votre liste aux élections
municipales aux chaînés puisque vous
êtes candidat vous aurez des
manifestants de la manif pour tous qui
vous rejoindront vous aurez un label
mais j'aurai des femmes et des hommes
qui défendent les idées de la famille
qui indique fondamentales de la
république
bien évidemment il y aura un label mais
la belle mais je répète les homosexuels
aussi dans ma liste ça ne me dérange en
aucun cas laisser cette question du
label sur la liste est ce que ce serait
une liste ump manif pour tous a le label
suivez le boeuf je pense que les labels
je vous laisse maître de votre
comparaison bah non mais écoutez moi je
dis non c'est une accréditation qu'il
faudra avoir et les gens auront besoin
de voir clair oui effectivement on dira
ce que les gens ont fait ou non pas fait
et il ya beaucoup de choses qui ne sont
pas faites et une remise en question
évidente de la politique en france c'est
le vrai challenge ils tiennent dernière
question que j'aimerais vous poser ce
sera une question qui sera appuyée d'une
photo c'était lors de la dernière
manifestation sur paris la mobilisation
avec les différents élus vous étiez vous
étiez présent je suis là vettier
derrière cette banderole oui on peut le
voir christine boutin également ou
encore le sénateur le sénateur alain
gournac également et surtout on voit
gilbert collard louis jt du
rassemblement bleu marine oui les
et front national louis gill a beaucoup
fait parler cette fête photo le fait que
des élus ump soit à côté des élus front
national est ce que ça vous a gêné un
moment de la manifestation d'être à côté
de gilbert collard je pense que toutes
celles et ceux qui défendent les valeurs
ne doivent pas être rejetées et que moi
je défends des idées appartements les
personnes défendent des idées imaginant
que gilbert collard face le mémoire pour
défendre au conseil constitutionnel est
ce que les gens ne l'accepterai ou pas
peut-être que oui donc moi je dis
aujourd'hui que monsieur collard n'est
pas pestiférés voilà il est là il défend
des idées qui peuvent être partagées la
seule chose c'est que j'ai regretté
qu'il soit pas dans l'hémicycle pour
voter voilà sinon bye bye à christine
boutin non mais je pense qu'aujourd'hui
le sujet est aussi bien à droite qu'à
gauche et que monsieur collard ne
représente pas le front national je
crois d'ailleurs qu'il est pas inscrit
au front national ceci dit les députés
du rassemblement bleu marine ils
célèbrent avec le rassemblement c'est à
ce titre là qu'il était présent avec
cette banderole d'élus merci fibrinogène
raclée en plateau avec nous je vais
également cité un communiqué d'un autre
élu huit mois qui n'est pas sur ce
plateau et qui lui est en revanche vous
aviez d'ailleurs débattu avec lui il ya
quelques mois sur ce plateau plutôt
satisfait de cette loi et direct est le
maire parti radical gauche de carrières
sous poissy et je le cite le 23 avril
est désormais une date à rajouter à la
longue liste des moments marquants de
l'histoire pour la lutte pour l'égalité
des droits merci à vous nous verrons
maintenant ce qu'en pense le conseil
constitutionnel puisqu'il a été
également saisis et puis ensuite viendra
le temps que la publication des décrets